it's exciting to see how how not only in  in Hollywood but around the world how  animation is flourishing how the short  film is flourishing in not only in  animation and live-action how feature  animations many many studios are  producing feature animated films and the  fact that we have an Academy Award for  Best Animated Feature Film yay you know  I'm so excited about that before you  know an animated feature film would only  if we're lucky get it get a music  nomination or or something like that I  mean only one film in history Beauty and  the Beast was nominated Best Picture and  so to have an award that celebrates the  film as a whole I think is fantastic